luno the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto
it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to another episode of
the leia hill plan show so today is going to be
a lot of fun but before i introduce my guests um
this particular episode is sponsored by coincorner
the uk and europe focus bitcoin exchange that
offers very lucrative bitcoin cashback when you
shop online it's even up to 40 with some partners
and they have over a thousand different partners
and merchants so pretty cool all you have to do
is just add the browser extension and then you can
get cashback when you shop online in bitcoin which
i think is great so i'm gonna leave um a link for
you guys somewhere um in the description um and
there you go just just go for it all right guys
so today before i introduce my guest please don't
forget if you are watching on youtube don't forget
to subscribe and hit the like button so you never
miss any of these interviews so joining me today
is the host of cnbc's crypto trader and the host
of your beloved youtube channel it is ran nuna of
crypto banter nearly stumbled on it there how you
doing ran how are you i'm good how are you doing
fantastic fantastic another great day another
another quiet day in crypto with this litecoin
news litecoin walmart news i mean just when i
thought i had my show all cut out one month before
the news breaks it's garbage so i had to put
it all together but we're good well since you
bring that up let's just talk about it because it
literally just happened litecoin did in fact spike
20 and then it dropped what do you think happened
was this somebody trying to do a quick pump and
dump or was this a genuine kind of mistake i think
it's much more malicious than we think because
i think what they showed now is how easy
the entire crypto market is manipulated
and if you kind of think about the substance
in the news and to be honest when i first heard
the news i warned the guys at the office i said
look this doesn't sound right because if walmart
it would be very logical for walmart to adopt
crypto that's like obvious yeah but it would be
crazy for them to adopt litecoin and i don't mean
that with any disrespect to like coin community
but what you would do is you would adopt a basket
of crypto currencies because the switches are all
exactly the same and you'd say we have you know
we're starting to accept crypto and you'd accept
bitcoin as the most accepted crypto in the world
you'd accept bitcoin on some kind of lightning
channel or something like that so i mean it was
suspect but when cnbc confirmed it and reuters
confirmed it and i mean i looked at there's
nothing hold on it's it's not like it's it's
cnbc it's reuters it's gotta be news so i laid out
the whole show now we changed the whole show to
be a light coin focused show and then as the show
went live we started seeing it maybe fake news so
we had to go back to the to some kind of mix of
between the original show and the litecoin show
but you're not so weird people are now calling
for more crypto regulation just because of this
well i i but i'd be interested to see what's
going on that's what it was about it was about
showing how easy it is to manipulate the
crypto market so people like gary gensler
are looking at this and going you know they've got
now another bullet in the arsenal to say to us hey
guys you know you want a bitcoin etf and you want
a litecoin etf but look how easily manipulated
the crypto market is where one new story can drive
the price up ten percent in in a matter of fifteen
minutes and then five minutes later all the retail
hands get get dumped uh and get stopped out and
that's exactly what happened in fact i was looking
at the liquidation stats on litecoin and i mean
they're crazy like the number of people that
got stopped out and liquidated on litecoin
was insane what do you have the numbers
uh yeah i can quickly call them up for you
uh what it shows though is a system which we've
covered before on our show um a system of how to
manipulate crypto so what you do is you go to a
a good sounding so let's look at the the quickest
quickly look at the one hour numbers um okay so
those are the one-hour numbers so you can see
that read them out read them out because people
will be listening on audio about a million dollars
worth of litecoin got stopped but when i was
looking at it i was looking at the number of
accounts so it's all small retail hands accounts
that got stopped out and that's in the last sorry
that's the last hour hold let me take you back
four hours because that would so 25 million
got stopped on litecoin um 143 143 000 litecoin
so this is the people that were stopped
the number the clue is actually in the
number here where you see that there's 151
000 litecoin that were actually stopped 151 000
accounts that were actually liquidated and the
vast majority of those were like coin accounts
that's so insane just showing how easy it is to
manipulate the crypto market and that's the sad
thing that is unbelievable i mean what would be
more interesting for me would be to see some
actual journalism and some fact checking because
when you've got people like like reuters and cnbc
confirming this i mean reuters and cnbc that was
my telltale sign that this thing might actually
be real you kind of believe something but the
formula is simple you go to a newswire that sounds
credible and in this one it was called global
newswire it sounds like i think it was globe i
think it was globe newswire as opposed to global
it sounds all credible yeah and then all the
other all the news artists pick it up because
they want to be the first and they kind of fomo
into breaking the news and they do absolutely
no research and then by that time this fake news
actually become real news you know by that time
the fake news actually is real news and yeah i
mean then the crypto markets have been manipulated
and it's the poor retail investor that gets
stopped out so with a very small amount of money
you can destroy and wreck retail investors
that's insane so when you say um you know
these are people trying to prove a point
about how volatile and immature this market is
you genuinely think that this is for this
came from a malicious place this came from
perhaps people trying to prove a point that it
does indeed need to be regulated correct that
of people that wanted to get out of a litecoin
position which doesn't really make sense and if
you watch the markets bitcoin went up and like so
litecoin went up first and then bitcoin went up so
i mean yeah absolutely it's sad it's a it's a it's
actually a bad day for crypto it's a bad day for
crypto it's a sad day for crypto because we're
gonna get sorry go around we want the markets to
be filled with integrity and we want the markets
to be sophisticated markets and good markets
and when this happens it just you know all the
hard work that we do to bring credibility to
these markets gets killed and it's that it's
it's someone in crypto it's sad that there's
so much manipulation i know there's manipulation
in every market in the world in gold in oil in in
everything else but you know crypto because the
market caps are so small is so easy to manipulate
and specifically when you manipulate crypto you
manipulate against the retail investor so you
know the retail investor is the one that gets hurt
arguably when stock markets are manipulated it's
hedge funds manipulating and liquidating other
hedge funds here it's the retail investor that's
getting blown out the water by fake news so what's
the solution to this are you pro-regulation then
i am pro-regulation um i think i think if you
if you think that crypto is going to remain
unregulated and i mean let's just rewind what
do we mean by crypto remaining unregulated the
fastest way to transfer assets around the world at
the lowest possible commission with no bureaucracy
whatsoever if you think that that industry is not
going to get regulated you're living in a dream
like it's it's it's not not an option it's going
to be highly regulated now i'm all for regulation
but i think it's going to be logical regulation
it's going to be regulation for the right reason
the type of regulation that we saw with the
infrastructurable garbage you know um uneducated
uninformed politicians lobbying for points
inserting um unthought through regulation
into another bill that's not regulation
but i do think we need regulation because
that will bring more money into crypto and
ultimately it will protect the retail investor
so i want to learn more about you ran um i don't
know loads um and i want to go back a little bit
before crypto before before those days um you're
obviously um based in south africa um you've done
a lot you're um you know you do work with cnbc
but i really want to understand what you did
um before crypto you know in your 20s in your
30s what was life before crypto i'll take you
on a little journey so in my 20s i've always been
a crazy entrepreneur built and sold many companies
in 1998 i raised a lot of money from a lot of
people to start an online stock broking stock
broking portal um i raised a lot of money i
was i was set to become one of the youngest
internet company directors on the stock exchange
here um we were building in the internet bubble
and in 2000 when the bubble popped so did
our company and so did run so run became
run was broke broke to the extent that i
had to go back and live with my parents
broke to the extent that i had to mortgage my car
broke to the extent that i couldn't afford to go
out to restaurants because i didn't have money
and i couldn't be bombing with my dad anymore
just like it was embarrassing how many times
can you take twenty dollars from your dad it's
it's embarrassing um so i was down and art so i
threw myself a probably a three-month pity party
i didn't do much i had a pity party and then
i started looking for things to do and i had
a girlfriend who was doing what we call in-store
promotions that's you know when people do you know
alcohol promotions or toothpaste promotions in
inside supermarkets and i went to visit her in
a store one day and a few things happened the
first thing is she wasn't there which showed
me that they monitored the second thing is i
saw 60 other people doing in-store promotions
um and they were untrained and they were
terrible salespeople and i thought hold
on i could do this better and i started a
marketing agency and it became the biggest
marketing and sales agency in africa fast forward
15 years i sold that to a company called publicis
in the biggest media and marketing
transaction on the african continent
promised myself i was going to retire
found bitcoin went down the rabbit hole and
that began my crypto life so i started
investing in in many crypto companies and
in between wait wait wait but how did you find
bitcoin how did you how did you discover crypto
um so it came to me from a couple of places but
in late 2014 early 2015 a friend of mine said
i'm bi and he's always been like you know every
group is like the early adopter friend like that
one friend was a gamer and he's always uh and he
came to me said i'm buying this magic internet
money and it just keeps video magic internet video
game money it's called bitcoin and it just keeps
going up in value you know i'm a dj gambler so i
was like okay well if it keeps going up in value
buy me ten thousand dollars worth of stuff and
then i bought ten thousand dollars and it doubled
and i was like hold on it's the easiest money
ever made buy me another fifty thousand dollars
what was this this is end of 14 beginning of 15
december 14th this is when it all started and i
started buying bitcoin um just not knowing i had
no idea what this was other than the party line
which was this is magic internet money yeah um and
that began then i was starting then i started to
hold the stash of bitcoin you know when number go
up you start realizing you started reading about
what you actually bought i must admit i first read
about it i was like why do you need decentralized
money like what's wrong with government money
which i think is a big point i think the ordinary
man in the street doesn't really understand the
need for non-government money like nine out of ten
people can't see why the government is is is um is
detrimental to money management like no one sees
this or specifically at the time in 2014 and 15
we didn't have this money printing through covert
i think maybe now people are starting to wake
up but we've got to remember that nine out of
10 people still don't understand the need or
the concept of non-government-controlled money
it's a complicated concept because there's no
reason why the government shouldn't control money
to most people it's only the few people
you know the one out of ten which is
us in the crypto community that have started to
educate ourselves as to why the value of money
has been dropping and you know what and what the
fed has been doing and yeah so that was 2014 2015
in 2016 20 sorry in 2017 i went to cnbc and i
said look you know you got to be covering this
asset class it's called bitcoin bitcoin yeah
right it's scam money it's a ponzi scheme it's
i mean i heard all i heard all the buzz lines and
then eventually i met a friend of mine as one of
the directors i met him about something else and
i educated him about bitcoin and i think the penny
dropped for him and he said look don't speak to
my head of production so i went to the head of
production i spoke the head of production and
you know when you teach people about bitcoin
and there's that like one second where you see
their eyes light up and the penny drops yeah
so i was like i saw that look in her eyes i saw
like i saw she got it like i gave myself a pat
on the back and i said i obviously did a great job
teaching her about it and so i said look guys you
got to be covering this as the class and she says
yeah we do we need to have and all i wanted them
to do was actually to cover it on power lunch or
squawk box or whatever just like for three minutes
and she said this thing needs to have a weekly
show it can't be three minutes it needs to be
26 minutes and it needs to be live so i was like
great good luck with that if you need me call me
and she said what do you mean he said you're doing
the [ __ ] and i was like hold on a second weekly
big commitment yeah remember i just sold
my company so i kind of had the time
26 minutes that's a shitload of content in 2017.
and live i've never done tv before in my life and
you want me to sit there live and she said look
you'll have a production team and we'll teach
you how to do tv so i arrived back there the next
week and i've got a production team but i realize
the production team doesn't know much about
bitcoin so like they gave me stuff to look at i
was like no you can't say that that's not bitcoin
no one understood it so i said hold on i got this
and i phoned a whole lot of my friends in
crypto phone brock pierce spencer bogart
and i said listen next week wednesday ten o'clock
in the morning or whatever the time was i'm gonna
send you a zoom link and then you're gonna be live
on the first televised crypto show in the world
on cnbc and that's how we ran the show and i
looked back at my first shows i was terrible
i'm still terrible but i look back at the first
shows i was really terrible i was you could see
me reading off the prompter like this but i mean
i got through it and i got better and better and
now we are we are where we are today that's
such a fascinating story it's so interesting
you know that this happened all the way back in
2017 because even then i think that is so early
i think you know even now we have we struggle so
hard to get mainstream news outlets to even talk
respectively um in a respectful way about bitcoin
as we've seen you know with the el salvador and
and all that news coverage that i got um but
right now you're doing an amazing job with crypto
banter um you have one of the most incredible
communities um the most loyal community everybody
it's like one big family it's truly amazing so
i'd love to understand how you built that and
you know how you're able to create something so
powerful okay so i realized a few things when
i came out of cnbc and so i ran the once a week
show with cnbc and i realized a few things one is
once a week is not enough for crypto show because
the market moves way too quickly once an hour is
maybe not even enough for crypto show because the
market moves absolutely too quickly the second
thing is i realize that crypto people don't trust
cnbc as a new source facts they it has credibility
in other stuff but they don't trust it in crypto
they used to call me the counter indicator when i
was at cnbc they said cnbc is the county indicator
when cnbc says buy you sold the third thing that i
realized was crypto people don't relate to suits
and tires they don't want a guy in a suit and tie
talking to them in a studio sitting there with
his posture with his hands on the counter and
and protect they want you to be who you are
yeah and that was the biggest lesson that i got
that if i'm authentic transparent honest
with my community then they will trust us
and the more authentic we became and the more
we realized that actually the whole reason why
we're doing this is about community and we don't
actually care we've become absolutely selfless
we don't care about ourselves we do not care
about ourselves we only care about the community
we we make sure we get allocations for our
community we do give away we gave away like
a million dollars in a week two weeks ago
to the community no how did you do that
we got offered allocations in ideos right we
decided to instead of taking their locations first
to take them and to get the entire community and
the allocations came onto the market at 50 100
200 x and we just gave it to the community
and we said and we did it at pre-ido prices
so even though we knew what the price was we knew
they'd done a 30x or a 40x we still gave them 100
each in pre-rdos so what i realized was and it's
actually a big lesson in my life for me it's
just give just give you don't need any more i
don't need anymore like i'm not i'm not very
wealthy on international levels but i don't
really need any more and i get much more joy
and passion giving to the community and when
you start to give selflessly transparently
authentically without expecting anything back this
the biggest thing happened this community just
became loyal to us and they became like a family
and we saw this when my producer's father passed
away he passed away from covert and the community
was like we're like his biggest support structure
and then we brought a new member into the
family who's a trader his name is sheldon
sheldon was a carpenter who lost his father less
than 12 months ago he was broke he had to sell
his carpenting equipment but he realized he had a
gift for charting and i discovered him and i said
you know what i just want to i want to just change
your life and i brought him onto banter and i said
banta fan meet sheldon and i told him the sheldon
story that sheldon story has been viewed over 300
000 times on youtube and they love him and he's
part of the family and we've got this like banter
fam family where the family explodes every day
all we do is give all we just give we never ever
ever our motto is we never ever ever ever ever
take money from our community for anything
no money from any member of the community ever
for anything no subscriptions no no paywalls
nothing we even we have a school i pay teachers we
created a syllabus the school is free it's we're
going to put a million people through school
by the end of 2022 and it is free it's costing
us money but we're going to put a million people
through crypto school in 2012 by the end of 2022
for free what does crypto school look like
it is 100 people per class live classes
you get you get it put into groups of 10 in the
class uh there's three streams the first stream
is an introduction to crypto investing and that is
uh starts off with a history of money goes into uh
understanding centralization understanding network
effects bitcoin bitcoin versus gold yeah ethereum
altcoins and bitcoin disruption uh exchanges and
wallets security and scams and then it ends off
with building a crypto portfolio and by the end
of the first module all we want you to do is to
be able to have a conversation about any altcoin
and be able to build a crypto portfolio and if
we've done that then we've achieved our objective
that's stream number one once you've graduated
from street number one you can be accepted into
stream number two and that is making a career out
of crypto so if you want to know how to speak
if you want to know how to analyze tokenomics
if you want to know how to chart if you want
you know there's so many different ways to make
money out of crypto so we are we'll then take you
into what we call sniper school and that's like
the second scripter school then sniper
school where you can make the the most
accurate trades and then we teach you trading
staking psychology of investing um you know
different portfolio strategies stuff like that
and the third stream is a separate stream which
is crypto for institutions and that is uh how
do i reward my consumers with crypto how do i
accept crypto where do i store the crypto uh
what are the positives or the the negatives uh
you know where do i keep my crypto treasury
stuff like that so it's three streams
uh and our objective is a million people by the
end of 2022 and all three that's incredible i love
that so much i find the information right now is
that there's such a barrier to entry because the
information is so difficult and also there's just
so much information so people don't really know
where to start so having a place where people
can go um and just have everything organized
into some kind of educational format i think it's
great it's amazing that it's free um but i want to
just tell you i think i did tell you um but i want
to let your um your audience know as well talking
speaking of how big the banter family is a
few months ago i was just out having breakfast
somewhere in london and um this guy just sitting
next to me was just watching you on youtube
um and he was like do you know do you know do
you know rand you know crypto banter and i was
like yeah yeah i know them um and then you i
think you'd used one of my videos on your show
and then he doubled it yeah and then he doubled
takes and looked at me twice and he was like that
was you and i was like yeah that was me so
it's such a small world i can't believe just
some little place in like the outskirts of london
i was just sitting for breakfast you won't believe
how popular crypto is in it and like when i go for
a run in the mornings in in new york or in miami
i live in miami so when i go to york or miami and
i'm running people spot me when i entered the us
the tsa official that actually checks you in oh
that checked on him and he tried to keep it see
he was like looking at me and like and at the end
of it he said so what do you think should i be
buying bitcoin or litecoin right now i'm like how
do you know i watch you every single day so it's
like i think like there's just people everywhere
that watch you and again i think it's because of
our attitude where we just give it's free we don't
want anything back from the community except maybe
a like and a subscribe um and we're authentic we
disclose all our holdings we tell people when we
invest um you know we don't we have a lot of
rules like you can't sell any token if you've
spoken about on the show for i don't know i don't
remember the numbers but it's like 48 hours so we
can never pump in our community so we're trying
to build i want to take on cnbc not take one i
want to run a parallel to cnbc i'm going to have
you think about the traditional financial world
you can switch on cnbc or bloomberg at any
time of a day or night and within 30 minutes
you've got you know exactly what's happening
on the markets from a live credible source
with crypto that doesn't exist with crypto you
have to go to twitter and good luck finding
credible information on twitter then you have to
go to telegram and i don't know what your telegram
looks like but if it's anything like my telegram
no chance so there's no way to get it there's not
one button where you can go live credible 24 7
365 streaming of crypto content and that's the
market that i want live not in for long form i
want to be live if you want live information that
is credible 24 7 365 go to crypto banter that's
what we're building we're going to take on cnbc
we're going to become the parallel in the crypto
universe and one day we're going to buy them
damn i love it i think that's amazing um but i
want to delve into altcoins with you because you
know a lot um your followers say you know a lot
so i want to go into i have a lot of questions
so you said recently that you sold your ethereum
for seoul is that correct yeah i sold about 60 of
my east and i put the money into solana and i put
the money in between twenty five dollars and about
fifty dollars actually eight i bought some
more at eighty dollars at about eighty dollars
okay so talk me through this a lot of people
say that solana is the ethereum killer
why why does it have to be the ethereum killer
and for it to be an ethereum killer they have
to be direct competitors and are they well it
depends how you see it i think what we've realized
let's talk about what ethereum is let's understand
what is it there so to most people ethereum is a
smart contract blockchain that's how you see it to
me ethereum is a call option on multiple different
blockchain experiments which may all disrupt the
world so if you think about the two that have
succeeded out of the hundreds that have happened
one of them is d5 and the second one is nfts
what we have realized with the with
d5 disruption and the nft disruption
is that if any other experiments are built we're
going to need a lot of blockchain capacity because
if you've seen what nfts have done to ethereum
they've made ethereum not usable arguably nfts
are in the beginning beginning beginning of their
life cycle we haven't even seen one percent of the
disruption that nfts are going to do and the
biggest blockchain that we have by market cap
can't handle the transactions
to the extent that it is
broken useless and unusable to the majority
of people right it's it's it's it's unusable
so with that thesis in mind i'm not saying that
they're going to be ethereum killers but i'm
saying there probably are going to need to be a
whole lot of blockchains that are going to work
then i worked i worked on who are the blockchains
and what chance they've got of success
so for a blockchain to succeed
you need great technology
you need a developer ecosystem which has like
like the reason why ethereum worked is because all
developers believed in decentralization and that
ethos so you can't have a centralized blockchain
and then you need money you need
vc money yeah so i look at solana
has vc money in the form of sam bankman feed
multi-coin capital and a whole lot of investors
it has incredible technology it has
the the fastest technology that i know
for smart contract blockchain finality it
is decentralized enough and it is scalable
so that's when i when i realized that
and i saw what was going on with nfts
i thought you know what i know that i'm i'm
passionate about ethereum but i'm actually going
to be a big boy and i'm going to say you know what
i like it because i'm emotionally attached to it
but logically solana has to work and solana worked
and then i looked at cardano and i said hold on uh
love carano great technology so lifeguard
honor because if you understand the technology
on cardano corona is very sophisticated
technology that makes blockchain very simple
okay so karana is going to make blockchain very
simple and corona has a lot of money behind it
um it has a very very very loyal community in fact
only now we are seeing that the solana community
is staking more than the cardano community yeah
and as of yesterday cordano has smart contracts
so now you've got two very viable options but
celana has much more traction than cordano and
so that's why i put a lot of money into solana
and a little bit into corano and then i bought
a little bit more of avex because i said look we
need a lot of smart contract technology because
none of the layers are going to be able to fill
it up and avex is the one that is up and coming
and so i put a small little bit on avex so that's
my thesis around smart contract blockchains and i
do believe that they will all succeed and there
will be space for all of them and i think that
in the long long long term ethereum is going
to be the biggest underperformer you think the
thing which gets me about these blockchains
is they're all doing very similar things and
it's very difficult i find to really get to grips
with you know the the the detailed intricacies
which make them just slightly different a lot of
them are working on you know uh interoperability
a lot of them are working on smart contracts d5
nfts daps you know the whole thing um so when you
look at something like solana and a lot of people
say it's the ethereum killer how does that then
how does that then compare for example to binance
smart chain because a lot of people were saying
back in april during the peak of the bull market
that binary smart chain is going to completely
destroy ethereum even though it's kind of like a
copy of it so how where does binance marching come
into it for you finance smart chain binary smart
chain is a tricky one because if you look at the
bnb token it's a token for an exchange and it's
also an exchange a token for a smart chain yeah
so it has it's i mean it has its pros and cons on
the one hand if the exchange fails the smart chain
will work if the smart chain fails the exchange
may work so you may have be you know diversified
on the other hand i don't know have you ever
used binance smart chain it's a clunky experience
i use it just for like trading and if i'm on like
pancake swap or something like that experience
it's because it's a fork of ethereum it's much
much much more centralized than ethereum and
much more senseless it's it's very cheap and at
one stage a lot of people are building on it but
if you want decentralization and you want to go
from i don't know 20 or 30 validators or whatever
the number of validators are on the binance smart
chain to 700 validators which makes it a lot more
decentralized then you go to solana from a speed
point of view celina has blockchain finalization
in 0.4 of a second and they do this through a
piece of technology where they've embedded a clock
a watch clock into their technology so and the
reason for that is most the time blockchain
systems are working out what came first and what
came second they have to agree on what happened
before what what solana did was embed a clock
and said you know if you've got a clock then
the clock tells us what came first and what
came second and so they don't have to argue
about what came first and what came second and
they don't have to reach that level of consensus
which makes the line of the fastest
blockchain out there i don't know of any
blockchain that settles transaction faster than
salina but you said you think say that again sorry
i don't know any any blockchain that
settles finality faster than solana
but you said that you think ethereum will
come last in this race which is really interesting
because obviously there's ether 2.0 coming
proof of state coming eventually yeah do you
not think that's going to change things a bit
do you not think ethereum still has
that first mover advantage so that when
if 2.0 does come you know it might sort of kill
the other competitors interesting question so
traditionally i would have said to you that each
cannot be disrupted and the reason why it cannot
be disrupted is the same reason why bitcoin can't
be disrupted and that is because it has network
effects so for people watching we don't know what
network effects are it's like a it's like whatsapp
with every user that joins the network you can
make more calls in the network and therefore the
network is worth more exponentially so if leia
and i on on whatsapp the maximum number of calls
we can do is i can phone layer and she can phone
me that's two calls if we add a third person then
you know fred that i can phone leia leia can phone
me i can phone fred fred can phone me freaking
phone layer and so we increase the number of calls
that can be made on the network exponentially
yes once something has network effect the rule
is that it cannot be stopped and in fact even
the growth of it can't be stopped so it's
it's the reason why investors are so happy
to pay a premium for facebook for amazon for
google because they all have network effect
so there are only three things that can
stop a protocol that has network effect
in the world government intervention is one so if
the government says hey bitcoin is banned ethereum
is bad you're going to stop the network effect the
second one is a um a breakdown in the technology
so i'm going to park that one for a second okay
and the third one is a competitor which is 10x
better has a small potential to be able
to steal market share from the incumbent
so traditionally i would say that any protocol
that has network effect can't be stopped
but in this case i think ethereum has been on
two of the three axes actually may be stopped
one is the technology doesn't
work it's just not fit for purpose
right and it's fit for purpose at a time where
lots of vcs are allocating money to blockchain
development because they're seeing just how
promising blockchain development is yeah
so they are taking their money from ethereum
and they're putting the money into celina
right now right now we're seeing a huge
shift of money from ethereum to celina
the second thing is that celina may actually be
10 times better than the current east product
so great you've promised us this east 2.0 but the
problem is you're taking too long to get to market
and because you're taking too long to get to
market you're opening the door for disruption and
so it's very very interesting that i think that
in most cases even if you have a slightly better
technology you cannot break the network effect
but in this case you have a better technology
and you have a technological failure and
therefore i think that ethereum is at risk of
being disrupted and then you add on one more thing
and you say this blockchain disruption is so big
that no layer one is going to be able to handle it
on its own and so there's space for more than one
and then you go back to who's got the
best technology the most vibrant community
the greatest ethos and the most money coming in
and solana maybe cardano um yeah i mean that's
that's where the money is going i sort of look
at it as similar to social media platforms yes so
you could say in some sense when they were first
built people the developers didn't necessarily
know that twitter was going to be built for
journalists and let's just say intellectuals
or whatever you know people that like want to have
that kind of debate and that kind of conversation
i don't think they had that in mind as opposed
to you know facebook being built that way and
instagram being more picturesque and i don't
think they had that in mind i think it's kind of
how they evolved naturally based on what their
algorithms could do and what their technology
could do and i sort of see it like that and i
think that they won't necessarily all survive
but i definitely think more than one will survive
i think it's just arrogant in my opinion and
ignorant to think that only one blockchain will
survive um i am talking across the mark i think
10 blockchains will survive maybe even more
bitcoin is going to survive and it's going to
be the ultimate store of value it's got network
effects the technology is great it's proven it's
been battle tested a million times it's amazing
decentralized so bitcoin bitcoin is safe yeah okay
then we move on to smart contract blockchains
ethereum very decentralized eth 2.0 will be
amazing when it launches um but it's still not
fast it's still not 0.4 of a second to finality
now that's okay for large-scale default
transactions institutional d5 transactions
where you're more worried about decentralization
and security than you are about speed okay so then
this will be a great blockchain for that what
about the traders who need split-second speed
celina what about the what about video gamers who
need split-second speed because that's the game
solana so different blockchains will do different
things and i think the nuances are going to become
you know cardano and ethereum are going
to be a little bit more centralized than
uh decentralized in solana so people who really
need decentralization as the as the key access
security and decentralization we'll go to the
ethereum guys and that is we'll go to salina
the other thing that we not talking about here but
we should talk about is bridges um yeah right now
token bridges are clanky like it's clunky it's
a it's a yeah it is it's a terrible experience
it's like bridging a token from one place that
it gives you anxiety you've got to take two
xanax before you bridge them and then you hope
the tokens come out on the other side and that
you have an input inputted something incorrectly
and i mean yes even just sending a transaction
no like even just still sending transactions
still gives me anxiety because i'm like
is it correct did the copy paste work is it going
to go to the correct address it's not wrapped
it's the actual legit coin it still gets me really
honestly the polygon somatic polygon bridge to
get yeah chromosome to polygon is quite quick
but when you send the tokens back from polygon
to ethereum like because of the ethereum
system it could take like hours many hours
so if you're sending reasonable amounts of money
and you have to wait hours i mean i just sit there
and i'm like when is this money gonna rap when is
this money gonna arrive when is this money gonna
arrive so right now bridges are clunky they're
not user-friendly they're getting better but
they're not user-friendly and there's a lot of
fees associated like you've got to wrap the token
one transaction and you've got to send those into
the token over the network another transaction
but that is going to become almost seamless in
time that is going to become almost seamless
so i think there is a massive play on bridge
technology and there are good bridges out there
but people are discarding how important the
bridges are from hopping from one network to
another network to another network to another
network and one day i think all these bridges
will just be interconnected um i think so yeah
speaking of which interconnected we don't talk
about polkadot and kusama which are just this i
was going to get to go on but all these specialist
blockchains and that for me i was sitting
this weekend and i was thinking you know this
blockchain disruption is so big and no layer one
can handle the transactions so who's going to win
and that just thought to himself who is
the most scalable blockchain of all of them
another what's going to be kosama or
pocket because what they do is they
connect a whole lot of specialist blockchain so
they connect like a moon river is the ethereum
equivalent which is ca it's it's a it's a it's
ethereum but plugged into kusama and just think
about ethereum one and ethereum two and a theorem
three and then a special d5 chain and an ai chain
all plugged into one bridge so you got 100 chains
and they're all plugged into one bridge and they
transact seamlessly on what they call the
substrate network which is the kusama network
and to me i just that's when i realized just
how big and how scalable the kusama network
and the polkadot network will actually become
so i mean no one's talking about these yet
but i think that those two are also like the two
horses that are in the race you know it's like
a horse race and they're like we're like in the
beginning of the race and they're all in the pack
but looking and going hold on that's the horse
that's going to break out at the end and i'm
going to give it like a big run at the end
and i think that's what's going to happen
i totally agree with you i'm looking into all
those projects that you mentioned right now kasama
substrate uh polka dot i'm looking into all of
them investing probably more than i should um but
whatever my mind is going to lose value anyway if
i don't invest it so that's kind of my mentality
um but you kind of did just mention it you know
you spoke about scalability decentralization
um but what are the main kind of um i guess
trends and indicators that you look for
um when you're wanting to find something
new to invest in follow the smart money
what does that mean though that's like a
cute catchphrase but like what does it mean
so what i've realized is if i look at avex
avalanche and i look at r-weave which is
in my mind one of the one of the you know
the best blockchain protocols out there um
what i realized is that the smartest money in
the world and the smartest money in the world
like andreessen horowitz polychain capital
pantera multi-coin capital these are people
that have a lot of resources they spend a lot of
time researching things they have a lot of money
they see a broad view of the industry and they
decide to put big bets on these things as a
retail investor that's your queue to be jumping in
that's when it says follow the mark money you know
i mean i get a taste of it because because
we're in the in the media we see a broad range
of projects and because i have an an analytics
team on analyst team who research projects for me
i get a taste of what it must be like selling it
and recent we've also got a lot more money and
a lot more access and a lot more research than
i've got and it's a it's an amazing place to be
so for me the the the follow the smart money just
follow what the big fans are doing try and get if
i could do one thing all day long just understand
where the big fans are allocating their money and
understand it as quickly as possible because
you know everyone's talking about avalanche
and recent has funded avalanche for three rounds
the last of round if i'm not mistaken was last
year 2020 when no one even spoke about avalanche
no you know um if you did your research you'd
know that he was funding it and yes it was pretty
simple it was i'm going to just try and find it
first but um avalanche i'm gonna share your
screen again let me just find it and recent
andrei now you got the solana price up there i
like it on the price up later so uh let's have
a look here yeah so uh here we go i mean this
is june 2020 june 25th 2020 um base layer was
heat up with another 12 million committed to ava
labs ever launched blockchain avalanche and and
it was led by galaxy by andreessen by a whole lot
of others so you look at this and you go hold on
what did they know a year ago
that we're only finding out now
then i'm with you yeah so then follow the smart
money follow the smart money because you'll
never have the resources to do to catch up with
their resources so just follow what they're doing
so what projects are standing out to you right now
other than celina um so layer one block
chains so cordano solana avalanche
layer one because i don't think we have enough
layer ones luna the terra luna uh ecosystem
because of the adoption because of the genius of
how their stable coin works if you understand what
terra luna does so some people call it luna some
people call it terra there's a stable coin that
they create which is called terror no yeah or you
know i don't know which of one is a stable coin
uh it's the terra is a stable coin i think
the terrorist yeah i was going to say the
terror is a stable coin terrorist and they create
applications which create use case for more terror
and the more applications that they create
the more terror need to be created to meet the
demand of consumers right so the more consumers
you get the more terror you have to create in
order to create terror you have to burn luna which
increases the supply of terror so you're watching
this this ecosystem where they are creating
more and more and more amazing applications
that are going to create more and more and more
users into the terra ecosystem and require a
whole lot more terror to do that they're going
to have to burn and reduce the supply of luna
so it's a no-brainer because they've
just started and they've got a market cap
of 4 billion dollars i mean whatever the number
is i haven't looked at it today but no-brainer
yeah i've been saying it since 35 cents now 35
people are starting to listen um that for me is
a great ecosystem another great ecosystem for me
the best i've been calling it again since 7 cents
and 10 cents and 35 cents are weave mm-hmm are
we was the most genius [ __ ] thing in the world
i decided i'm about to swear on your podcast
yeah you can't it's chill gone so it's it's
when you understand how genius are weavers
so you talk about file storage file storage
is a flawed industry so for one every file storage
provider in the world charges you per meg per
month per gig per month per terabyte per month
blah blah blah yeah and the information is not
stored forever and i know this because there were
articles written about me less than 10 years ago
which i look for on the internet and they don't
exist and that is because probably a good thing
well yeah some of them are great some especially
some of those photos um so what our weave does is
they are a blockchain so to speak and what they
do is they store data forever with one payment
so instead of paying every month you pay i don't
know what the number is but call it ten dollars
per x and then it is stored forever how they
have an endowment and what they do is they they
they charge you and they've worked out what they
think the the cost of storing data is going to be
and they've added like multiples in it
but remember this the cost of storing
data constantly gets reduced because computing
power gets cheaper storage space gets cheaper
and they've done the calculation and they take
the money and they have a very sophisticated
consensus algorithm which says to the block
manufacturers now the block manufacturers
in this case have to store data and they say
look if you store the data you need to store plus
some other random data which which it asks you
for and if you've got that you get the payment
so you're incentivized to store as much data as
possible and through that mathematically they can
guarantee you that your data is actually going to
be stored forever and so if you think about other
blockchains or other storage protocols either
google controls them or amazon controls them or
they may not be around forever and then you say
hold on if i'm buying an nft i'm buying a punk
and my cost me a couple of million dollars and i
want to hand it down from generation to generation
to generation i want it to last forever yeah
i'm publishing a world-changing life-changing
journalistic story i wanted to be there forever
and not to be able to be deleted and i wanted
to be there for another thousand you know when
when they brushing off our news like like we
do with the pyramids and the pharaohs i want it
to be i want it to be there forever and there's
actually only one system of protocol in the world
that does that and that's our weave so anything
that is super important to you should be stored on
our weave and there's no competitor it's not like
oh there's another one no one else does it it's
what's the technology well it's like was it like
proof of stake like what is that it's they have
their own consensus algorithm they've got a it's
it's a consensus algorithm where
you have to prove that you've got
that you've stored x plus some other random stuff
and i remember how they they what they call it but
that means that everybody that
stores data stores it forever
yeah and and again are we people just haven't
realized the power of our weave except now with
nfts where people are storing nfts there because
they're being stored forever another one is solana
realizes that they've got to store their data
somewhere where do they store the data on iweave
oh really where do you store blockchain data
the only place to store blockchain data forever
is on our weave and so solana is storing
their data on iweave and i think many more
blockchains will follow so for me are weave
no-brainer i mean come on you gotta be done
i don't know i i need to look this
up now i need to i need to do some uh
dyor do your own research yeah so yeah
for me luna solana are weave um karano
uh the leia wands and then i mean you
gotta have a speculative portfolio
i think everybody must have a speculative
portfolio um where you can have some fun um
well on that point i did ask people earlier
um what their questions were for you i had
one fun one which i thought i have to ask um which
kind of fits perfectly right now somebody said
if ryan had to put his entire life savings
on one coin he thinks will 10x by christmas
which one would he choose my entire life savings
on one point that will 10x by christmas wow
hold on let me let me look at the portfolio
oh damn that but i wouldn't put my entire life
savings on any coin i think that's just negligent
i think dot hasn't run yet i think
dot hasn't run yet which is which is
uh risky let me know which is which is good wow
life savings one coin probably somewhere in the
dot and kusama ecosystem i think that's good are
we of luna yeah the rest of the risky i'm scared
to put people into very risky coins because no you
don't have to no it's not financial advice it's
just it's just what you would do you tell them
one thing portfolio and they put 90 because they
think that's the coin and then they get themselves
wiped out yeah you've got to be careful with that
um another question that came through was um what
price um let me let me actually read it word for
word because it's written kind of readily um what
price did he pay for his first btc and his first
eth first btc somewhere around 500 don't remember
exactly but somewhere around 500 my first east
it's between six and nine dollars i think i missed
the idea i bought between six and nine dollars
damn um okay somebody's actually i'm
looking through the um live chat now
um i wasn't looking earlier but i'm looking now
um and people are asking about link and i can't
believe i've not brought that up i'd actually love
to hear your opinion on link link is amazing um as
an oracle solution it's got network effects as an
oracle solution um yeah that's not i mean i have
link in my portfolio but it's not as exciting
as it's really not as exciting as some of the
biggest coins you know some of the most exciting
coins it's going to be a fundamental part of every
portfolio but it's not like it's not one of the
coins that i think is going to change my life
or triple before christmas or you know i can't see
them taking over the world so i mean i mean it but
i wouldn't be putting my life savings into it
no way okay and then another question that i
have which is quite a funny one as well is um how
many times have you been rock pooled uh yeah many
many many i mean i i sent is you're gonna laugh
i think i sent don't quote me on the numbers but
i think i sent like a hund you know like 200
bitcoin to a fake bitcoin mining scam in 2016.
oh exactly i'll give you that yeah i mean they
gave you a guarantee that they were doubling
you they would double your bitcoin and my friends
were all drawing their bitcoin and i jumped into
the ponzi and i caught him with the number he gave
him 200 bitcoin which at the time was like 200 000
and then it took they took my 200 000
the next day they shut down the website
so i've been writing so crazy i've been ranked
in d5 i was involved in some of these hacks where
where i had tokens in liquidity pools or in pools
where they were hacked but i mean that's part of
why we make the 100x returns because we're
going to take more risk and every now and
then things are going to go wrong and we just
have to be we have to put on our big boy pants
so some more questions are coming through
i'm just going to i'm going to take two more
um and then and then we'll and then we'll
leave it um somebody's asking did they miss
the boat on seoul i imagine i
know your answer to this but go on
i mean if you talking to me about the next week or
two weeks i can't answer that but in the long term
i don't think we haven't even started yet i think
if you're gonna hold it for three four five years
you know i bought solana on my show live on the
show for forty two dollars everyone told me i
was crazy um and then it went back to twenty
two dollars and people started to hate me on
twitter and they said ah you bought you know forty
two dollars and we all bought after 42 dollars
no one's crying now no one's you know no
one's crying anymore it depends how long
your investment horizon is um i tweeted that i
said you know people are talking about whether
smart contracts will be a buy the rumor sell the
news on korano oh yeah that was me i tweeted that
who the [ __ ] is like quran is not about
today or tomorrow or next week or next month
i mean even if smart contracts didn't work they
would fix it and next week it would work you know
like who cares you're not buying blockchain
technology for today you're buying it for the
next five years of disruption and so like you
think you've missed the boat on solana now come
back in five years then then you'll see what what
missing the boat actually means celina is valued
at one-seventh of the value of ethereum okay
is it too late there you go there's your answer
so just finally then on um a personal note what's
your goal with everything you know crypto wise and
work wise um just to change people's lives change
touch touch the lives of everyone that comes
into contact with me my my i've just got this
thing of like if you spend every single day of
your life thinking about how you can change other
people's lives somehow it has to come back to you
and i can say that i'm trying to change the
life of every single person that works with me
my producers my my team my analysts my um traders
just you know we get allocations i give them
all the allocations uh no i don't think anyone
has taken a salary like it's just one of those
things where they make so much we just give
everything away that they don't actually need
their salaries um then i want to change the banter
community's life and then just in general like
i've got the means to change people's lives
i don't want anything in return i don't need
yeah more money would be great
but it's not about more money
um so just change as many lives as possible and
then watch other people who some were down and art
and some who weren't having a great time and just
watch them smile again and watch them like the fan
mail that you get you changed my life you put me
out of debt i managed to pay my my kids studying
you know no fuss car no yacht would give me the
same amount of pleasure as just changing other
people's lives and so hell just change other
people's lives and don't ask for anything in
return and don't expect anything in return and
yeah that's the aim the aim is just to ch to touch
and change as many lives as possible and do it
for free yeah and i think you'll do it with this
crypto score i mean you're doing it now anyway
with crypto banter but with the school with you
know one million do you say one million students
or users by the end of the year of next year yeah
end of next year yeah yeah that's amazing we'll
have to i mean i know we chat anyway but we'll
have to catch up as well when that's when that's
you know going and because i think that's amazing
i'm getting you to do a 10 minute show on banter
and you're going to start and it's going to be
like it's called microdose and leia's going
to do a few and she's going to fall so in love
with the banter community and then he's going
to want to do it every day and eventually
is going to do a daily show unbanned for
10 minutes and just give us the microdesk i
know it's going to happen i can feel it there
you go oh i have one like one last question
um i saw on your show today you were talking
about wife changing money what number is that um
it's not a number it's a it's you you need a lot
of money if you're life-changing money is a big
number i mean you know how expensive wives can be
right well i'm not a wife but i can imagine when
i am one i will be a pricey one so yes just for
the record i don't want to change my wife i'm i'm
okay i'm happily married i don't want to change
my life but it's a great term that we've that we
use a lot i like it i think it's brilliant when
i heard it i was like yeah yeah that's brilliant
you won't believe how many people send this mail
and say you know it's a derogatory mail how can
you keep saying wife changing money why don't
you use the term has been changing money um
why is changing's better we also on the show we
did like we broke up the tokens into categories
we said are there a one-night stand uh it's
like you know slap me around and then let me
go in the morning um like we said like don't
leave a toothbrush which means that you've got
to get in you've got to get out the same day like
you can't leave a toothbrush uh and then we said
like date me uh commitment and then like marry
me coins and like bitcoin and you won't believe
how many emails we got like saying you know just
derogatory to a woman i was like why you think
you think women don't also talk about one night
stands and you think women also don't talk about
slapping me around and and you know like it's
there are sensitive people in the world good luck
no i'm totally with you i mean we could do a whole
show talking about you know freedom of speech and
derogatory words because like who cares honestly
i think it's great i think it's fun i think
life-changing money is hilarious i thought it was
brilliant um and if anyone has a problem with it
then they that oh my god they've got more problems
they've got to deal with because that is literally
a problem with it then everything is cool there
you go perfect that's all that matters well ron
i want to thank you so much um and i want to
thank everybody for watching um and interacting
it's been really fun reading through all your
comments um and i'm really excited to potentially
come on crypto banter then amazingly we look
forward to having you and thank you thank
you thank you love this we should do it again for
sure alright guys we'll see you next week bye bye